what do you think of some of the
challenges for long-term space travel do
you think about this kind of stuff the
biological stuff yeah
um do you do you worry do you think
about radiation on Mars
uh and out in Space over periods of uh
actually the effects on the human body
forget even the radiation over periods
of months and years yeah
I think realistically we have a really
good handle on what the effects are
and we actually have the solution to
like everything it's just whether or not
we can like you know for instance one of
the you know in low earth orbit one of
the biggest challenges eventually after
your long-term space travel is bone
density loss and not having gravity you
know you actually have issues with a
handful of things and artificial gravity
is easy in terms of relatively easy in
terms of uh space flight you know you
can you can have two vehicles just
tethered together and you know just
spinning uh give it enough distance and
a decent enough spin velocity and you
can you can get one gene like relatively
easy we're talking again relatively easy
especially after talking about
theoretical physics like this is that's
easy stuff um we haven't done that yet
but like there's there's no reason why
we can't produce artificial gravity if
we say that that's
um you know a big enough hurdle that we
absolutely have to overcome this okay
cool we'll just spin up two vehicles
that are going to Mars and people will
have but you know that's the thing is
Mars is only about we'll say six months
there then you're hanging out on Mars
you have 38 of gravity and then six
months ish back people live on you know
the International Space Station at six
month stints we've had people for
basically a year up on the International
Space Station it's not like it's it's
not life-altering yeah you have a couple
days of not being able to walk very well
and you do have some bone density loss
and some other concerns
but like again that's
it's solvable and I think you know the
first missions to Mars
I think it might we might we'll probably
do the trade is it worth it to like land
on Mars and have a crippled crew that
can't even physically stand yet you know
for a day or two before they get their
you know feet from underneath them or is
it do we need to spin up
two Space Crafter you know a tether and
have like you can't do it like Starship
you know even though it's 30 feet wide
or nine meters wide if you spin it on
that one axis
um that's not enough space to get 1G uh
without your feet and your head being at
two different uh velocities so you get
really sick at all well you always feel
like you're falling your brain will tell
you that you're falling constantly
um but then again okay so this is this
is the whole thing is
I you know and I don't know if there's
we don't really have the data yet on
like going from zero g we know the
effects of that we know the effects of
1G really well that's our majority of
our data set but we don't really have
much data on the long-term effects of
uh you know 1 6 gravity like on the moon
or 38 gravity is it is 1 6 gravity
actually enough to counteract 95 of the
effects of low gravity or is it 15 for
you know is it 1 6 the is it like a
linear thing is 38 gravity totally you
know 38 as bad as one or whatever you
know is it a slight like where is it out
on the scale so there's a chance that we
don't need anywhere near one g of
gravity to counteract the bulk majority
of these problems we could have
0.1 G or whatever is the you know the
right compromise of of vehicle
complexity and human biology and all of
these other effects like we this is
absolutely a solvable thing that is and
and all we figure some of this out
through just experimentation 100 along
the way yep uh one of this is back to my
dating life I think one of the essential
fundamental research questions I'm
wondering about is uh the Dynamics and
um
so the details of how you have sex in
space
um asking for a friend of course I mean
that's there literally is sort of work
on this right because like if you think
about long-term space travel
I mean
sex is is uh
so like the there's the recreational
aspect of sex but the most important
aspect of sex for long-term space travel
is
um
uh procreations
and also the full biological cycle of
that so that from the embryo the
development of the baby the giving the
birth and all that kind of stuff so like
you know there's a lot of really
difficult
problems of biology there to understand
and uh but perhaps it's all some of that
again just like you said brilliantly
some of that can be just solved with
engineering outside of the human body by
creating a gravitational field like that
but maybe along the way you can figure
out how to do that without doing it but
we're balancing the cost and so on and
radiation is the other thing we know we
have a really good data set on what
radiation and doses do to humans like we
we know we can measure radiation we know
we can approximate you know and kind of
give edge cases for the Mars transient
and getting to Mars and being on Mars
and the simple answer to that is like at
the end of the day if we have to you
know dig into Mars or find a tunnel to
to live in so you get some extra mass in
between you and Cosmic radiation so be
it like that's the that's the answer
then again none of these are like
insolvable problems they're just things
the hurdles you would have to overcome
based on
you know the the risk exposure and the
posture there imagine being
the first
child the first baby born
outside of Earth
that'd be pretty cool yeah I would love
to be alive to see that that's a big one
I don't know if they'll um
I don't know because it's such a
dangerous thing it's so risky I think
that could be in our lifetime you think
so yeah
I I would like to think in a perfect
world of her thinking futurism then
30 to 50 years I definitely think we
could have a full-time like permanent
major civilizations you know like like
um uh like what blue origin wants to
develop where they have a a huge like
sphere you know and you're doing a lot
of uh especially heavy industry off of
Earth so you're not polluting earth like
that's makes so much sense to me
um I yeah I think I think we
we could live in a lifetime where you
know we thought the since the 50s and
60s that people are going to be living
and working in space like crazy and at
any given point we're lucky to have 12
people in space today
um
but I really think In Our Lifetime we're
finally getting to that point of
yeah that that's a reality